Many of us know desserts to be the last guilty pleasure after a meal,...
...but did you know that before the 17th century in Europe,...
...what we know as desserts were used to cleanse the palate between courses?
In many parts of the world, sugar was a rare and expensive ingredient.
It wasn't until colonists generated and expanded the production of sugar fields...
...through slave labor that the price of sugar was lowered.
By the mid-17th century, cookbooks dedicated to desserts were published.
With many different textures, colors, and flavors,...
...here are some of the best desserts that exist around the world.
Yakgwa, meaning "medicinal confection," got its name...
...because honey was known in Korea as healthy medicine.
Yakgwa is a deep-fried cookie soaked in honey for six to eight hours.
The history of this dessert is tied to special occasions like royal banquets or Chuseok.
Though originally enjoyed mostly by the upper class because of the honey,...
...it is commonly eaten today and still served for Chuseok.
The origins of this dessert are a bit murky,...
...with the Catalans saying their crema Catalana preceded France's creme brulee...
...as well as Britain saying its Trinity cream was the first.
However, thanks to chef Francois Massialot,...
...France has the oldest recipe in writing, dating back to 1691.
Creme brulee is a custard topped with sugar...
...that gets torched to create a caramelized, hardened top layer.